let's get some practice rewriting and
simplifying radical expressions so this
first exercise and these are all from
khan academy it says simplify the
expression by removing all factors that
are perfect squares from inside the
radicals and combine the and combine the
terms if the expression cannot be
simplified enter it as given all right
let's see what we can do here
so we have negative 40
the negative square root of 40 i should
say let me write a little bit bigger so
you can see that so the negative
square root of 40
plus
the square root of 90.
so let's see what perfect squares are in
40. so what immediately jumps out of me
is this it's divisible by 4 and 4 is a
perfect square so this is the negative
square root of
4 times 10
plus the square root of
well what jumps out at means is this is
divisible by 9 9 is a perfect square so
times 10. and if we look at the tens
here 10 10 does not have any perfect
squares in it anymore if you wanted to
do a full factorization of 10 a full
prime factorization it would be
it would be
2 times 5. so there's no perfect squares
in 10. and so we can work it work it out
from here this is the same thing as the
negative of the square root of 4 times
the square root of 10
plus the square root of 9
times the square root of 10 and we say
when i say square root i'm really saying
principal root the positive square root
so it's the negative of the positive
square root of 4 so that is so let me do
this in another color so it can be clear
so
this right here is 2.
this right here is 3 so it's going to be
equal to
negative
square roots of 10
plus 3 square roots of 10.
so if i have negative 2 of something and
i add 3 of that same something to it
that's going to be what well that's
going to be
1 square root of 10. now this last step
doesn't make full sense actually let me
let me slow it down a little bit i could
i could rewrite it this way i could
write it as 3 square roots of 10
minus 2 square roots of 10. that might
jump out a little bit clear if i have 3
of something and i were to take away 2
of that something in that case the
squares of tens well i'm going to be
left with just one of that something i'm
just going to be left with one square
root of 10 which we could just write as
the square root of 10. another way to
think about it is
another way to think about it is we
could
factor out a square root of 10 here
so you undistribute it do the distribute
distributive property in reverse that
would be the square root of 10 times
minus 2 which is of course this is just
1. so you're just left with the square
root of 10. so all of this simplifies to
square root of 10. let's do a few more
of these
so this says
simplify the expression by removing all
factors that are perfect squares from
inside the radicals and combining the
terms so essentially the same
same same idea
all right let's see what we can do
so this is interesting we have a square
root
a square root of one half so can i
well actually what could be interesting
is if i have a square root of something
times the square root of something else
so the square root of 180
times the square root of one half this
is the same thing as the square root
of
180 times one-half and this just comes
straight out of our exponent properties
it might look a little bit more familiar
if i wrote it as 180 to the one-half
power times one-half to the one-half
power is going to be equal to 180 times
one-half
to the one-half power taking the square
root the principal root is the same
thing as raising something to the
one-half power and so this is the square
root of 80 times one-half which is
going to be the square root of 90
which is equal to the square root of 9
times 10
and we just we just simplified square
root of 90 in the last problem that's
equal to the square root of 9 times the
square root or the principal root of 10
which is equal to 3 times the square
root of 10.
3 times the square root of 10.
all right let's keep going
so i have one more of these examples and
like always pause the video and see if
you can work through these on your own
before i work it out with you
simplify the expression by removing all
factors that are perfect squares okay
these are the same directions that we've
seen the last few times and so let's see
if i wanted to do if i wanted to
simplify this this is equal to
the square root of
well
64 times 2 is 128 and 64 is a perfect
square so i'm going to write it as 64
times 2
over
27 is 9 times 3 9 is a perfect square
so this is going to be the same thing
and there's a couple of ways that we
could think about it we could say this
is the same thing as
the square root of 64
times 2
over the square root of 9 times 3 which
is the same thing as the square root of
64 times the square root of 2
over square root of 9 times the square
root of 3 which is equal to this is 8
this is 3
so it would be 8 times the square root
of 2
over 3 times the square root of 3.
that's one way to say it or we could
even view the square root of 2 over the
square root of 3 as a square root of 2 3
so we could say this is
8 over 3
times the square root of
2 3. so these are all possible ways of
trying to tackle this so we could just
write it let's see have we removed all
factors that are perfect squares yes
from inside the radicals and we've
combined terms we weren't doing any
adding or subtracting here so it's
really just removing the perfect squares
from inside the radicals and i think
we've done that so we could say this is
going to be eight thirds
times the square root of two thirds and
there's other ways that you could
express this that would be equivalent
but
hopefully this this makes some sense